so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dobachiola
whatever you want to call me I'm here
with my co-host Marty O'Neill what's up
oh hello what's up guys what's up what's
up with this energy Marty I was
expecting a screen scream I'm cool guy
today
we just won because the bills won all
right I got you guys today is an episode
you have been asking for just as much as
Bring Your Sister Bring your dad bring
your mom and we brought my mom because
she's wild as hell my sister is a is a
big Fibber so I don't know if I want to
she's just we're just gonna argue all
right and my dad be soaking my dad would
be awesome if I can Wrangle him enough
to be politically correct for an hour
and a half and then um this episode this
episode you guys asked for all the time
introducing my little brother this is
Rocco hi hola hi all right so Marty's
been telling me yo you gotta eat your
brother on the show yeah
straight my you know he turns 18 soon I
can feel okay smoking weed in a room
turned 18 he became an official part of
the team recently yeah yeah if you guys
don't know Rocco helps with all our
social media all our YouTube stuff
everything all right all right so we're
just doing that right now how old are
you I am 18 18. the big one not kinda
no this is the bigger one 21's not that
no it's not that insane do you care
about drinking is that even on your
radar no
not at all completely straight edge my
generation was all burnt out but I'm
drinking by 21 I felt like right
it's not really like that right do kids
really drink no they do oh they do oh no
yeah 100 but just it doesn't seem I had
a thought I had a thought this weekend
is the is like nightclubs and bars is
that going to really be a thing for your
guys I don't I've never like in my high
school I've never seen like oh there's a
party but also never not one time or a
video game nerd kid oh but I'm like I
don't know I feel like I've still it's
not the same when you're not like
selling sags going on that's true that
makes sense football team doing stupid
stuff that you shouldn't be doing I was
in golf yeah he was in golf and VR so I
haven't had to worry you know what I
mean
um all right so this Fool's 18. this is
my little brother you guys for everyone
out there that's ever watched anything
in you know bathroom dabs taking long
hits in the bathroom it's because of
this fool I kept all the weed stuff away
from him you never saw anything no no
idea and it took and so Mom got the
tattoo she said I was like I searched it
up oh my God 11. maybe all the way out
of my way so hard mom I wasn't out of my
way so hard to keep this from him so he
never knew what I was doing and then my
mom goes and blasts on her arm and tells
him it's a secret
he's got a phone it's just one Google
and it's just Thomas with Pax and I was
like oh I didn't really shocked I wasn't
I don't know why I wasn't shocked but I
was just like
well you never saw anything and then
also I didn't care yeah I was like
Thomas is doing good but you never saw
anything either yeah I never did
everything I take my posters down my
what the only thing was smell I didn't
know what the smell was he just knew it
smelled like I just I just knew Thomas's
house smells good when I smelled that
smell anywhere else like it smells like
Thomas
wow so did you have were you like was
there a party that was disappointed or
you were like fired up no not at all I
wasn't like so like I I think I searched
it up at school too I was in like Middle
School I was like dope as you look and
it was him with packs and I wasn't like
oh my God what is wrong I didn't I
didn't really know I was just like did
you let your mom know that you knew what
was going on how long until they
realized you knew it was gonna well I
think right away at some point they knew
because I think I started watching your
videos and I'm like that and what
happened is merced's 80 000 it's not
that many people yeah
even smaller yeah but it's far from
herself 30 minutes yeah it's not that
far and then there's kids in the school
wearing stuff that I wear it's so sick
so he's like dude who is that's my
brother he wears stuff like that well oh
he owns by the time I was in high school
I had already known I was already
watching her stuff yeah but in Middle
School
no one was wearing it I just knew High
School it was yeah I found out in Middle
School like seventh grade like my
English teacher's class
and
that was that was it I just I remember
when I was in high school and I started
seeing people wearing his clothes I was
like that's so cool were kids coming up
to you like no one knew no I don't want
to show you a picture of him still to
this day I've only been recognized by
one person [ __ ] you're like are you
Thomas's brother and I was like yeah it
was so cool it was an experience I never
posted him ever until recent when he
started modeling for us people didn't
put two and two together knowing your
mind I don't think like okay all right I
just feel like he never saw no one ever
saw my face nope I never showed him
until he was old enough I said until
he's old enough to fight for himself
that was it I didn't want to like put
his face out there some idiot kids like
oh yeah you think you're cool that's
your brother and try to fight him
because I have to go shoot that kid
that's always thinking like don't do
nothing stupid I'll shoot somebody in
the face yeah that was always my problem
like I don't want to have to do that so
that's why I didn't show him especially
where we're from that's why I don't know
why I'm blue or red
it's a thing the Merced Vlog really like
I really felt for those first time
probably for everybody like your impact
on that area and just how do that how
everybody was just coming out and The
Vibes of it all and that was cool nobody
was weird it was awesome yeah it was
dope
yeah there was one weird dude I was
gonna leave that out okay but I was
gonna leave that out stop he watches our
stuff I don't want to make him feel bad
okay it was one weird guy yeah hey man
it's so nice bro I went right over it
and Trent doesn't have a mic you guys
went into the [ __ ] heart or Gangland
into one of those it was yeah I was 12th
Street yeah um because my mom was like
hey uh is your brother is laughing at me
think it's a joke tell him it's serious
Mike Rocco it's dead serious you see
someone weird walking up to me tell me
so I don't get shot in the head or I'll
get shot you see a car creeping you see
the windows up tell me because he
doesn't know what this is but I didn't
know what what position it was in we
were fine but my mom was tripping so I
tried to get some like armed security
guard to make her feel better yeah
6K so you just Bart trunk
and wanted six bands and I told them
where they go
yeah we're gonna have to charge you I'm
like oh I should have said merch head
somewhere not on Martin Luther King and
12th Street and uh we were fine dude
come on we were yeah we're sad we were
chill everything's good a bunch of happy
people like a bunch of stoked but I get
it Merced is wild everywhere is wild
anywhere is wild but what age were you
guys when you moved out of that area
this this dude almost never lived in
Merced no I did for a while no almost
ready go where'd you live as a kid I it
was in Merced until until when like
fourth grade fourth grade I moved to
Madera but I had windows in Hawaii for
four years yeah that's what I was trying
to do oh yeah yeah yeah he moved when he
was like three or four years old to away
it's okay my first memories were in
Hawaii and I think that's why I was a
little demon because my mom was like
we're going to Merced and I was like I
didn't know but I was like oh you guys
got the same dad no
this was six two okay I did not have the
same here okay so that's why we look
different he looks like my mom was he
around when your mom was with your
stepdad would not flanners oh okay so
this is what happened he my mom sucks
she explained the whole story never
explained anything to him I explained
his whole life story to him last week he
didn't know about his dad his grandma
Uncle Mickey our grandma my grandma mom
never told him any family stories I know
nothing about my family until the thing
I'm like what do you mean Grandpa you
really text Dragon what do you mean yeah
what do you mean Grandpa Tom you don't
know anything about your dad's side
about anything about my grandpa my
grandma like all I know about my grandpa
is he showed me hot dog cheese sandwich
and he fixed my RC car one time my
Grandpa died my grandpa Tom okay he
passed away when he was like seven okay
I was seven where are you oh seven it
was 11 years ago 18 oh yeah okay yeah
damn my mouth is bad
um so check us out his dad's a piece of
[ __ ] I don't like him but I told him the
story about his dad he's never heard
anything about him he's
dad's outside you know his dad's tight
as [ __ ] as a person but I'm like I gotta
be I hate him
it's a love hate for like what he did to
your mom no are you ready I told him the
whole story you're getting it Mom you're
probably no she explained it all to me
really good when we read my nails I was
doing my nails so Jade oh four days ago
so good though hold on brother your
nails are going crazy
no the other day he had full artwork for
my mom like sick painting on it yeah I
remember when you started doing I'm like
Get Ready Get ready to fight something
dude no one has said a word yeah because
I think they're like I don't want to
fight that kid and it's also like it's
only girls that are like those are cool
like I know they are that was the whole
point that's it like don't worry girls
will like it
don't worry you sing and girls will like
it don't worry about it you're fine
um
yeah I told the whole story of his dad
my mom was divorcing Ned Flanders prison
bird and he was still stalking her and
all this stuff I never talked about it
but he was doing weird stuff yeah she
explained it really good yeah for a
while right for a while and then his dad
came in the picture that's how I'm so
good with a butterfly knife he showed me
all that stuff that's why he's randomly
good as hell with way better something
like gangbanger [ __ ] or no he's a [ __ ]
dude he's six three white dude with a
beard look like shavo okay she has a
travel beard was he a prison Dude too
nope he's a car guys got sick cars
builds low riders and hot rods he's cool
as hell he's got a job I met him
[ __ ] my mom's new boyfriend here's the
story I was like I [ __ ] with my mom's
new boyfriend he's cool
and then
stupid [ __ ] kept coming around
and then mom's like yo uh well we'll
just call him dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] scared
away prison vertigo don't try to Hype
him up don't you dare say that he scared
him don't do that he just left because
he saw you were with somebody don't ever
say he was scared of him because don't
give him that much credit
[ __ ] with prison bird you'll kill him
dumb [ __ ] is way bigger than me
he was no no you don't [ __ ] with with
prison bird you know that everyone in
that town knows don't don't fight him
what's wrong with you oh so it's a known
thing about him oh okay I mean my dad
everybody knows there's a smoke met
together in high school Andy was
tweaking yeah yeah and he was tweaking
made him just longer that's what my dad
said he was really from there he's from
Merced they all everyone knows each
other they all [ __ ] bite met together
in high school
anyway
his dad my mom gets pregnant with him
and I remember my mom told me I was
passing 10th Street on R and I went you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you barely
barely [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all I thought
like I have to take care of a child
that's all I thought of like well I just
had a kid that's all I thought of
because I know my mom's not gonna [ __ ]
up but she was better but I knew it was
like calm you were how old about to be
15. she was 32. when she had him what
was her tone when she was saying it so
uh you've known this [ __ ] for
seven months when you're having a baby
you're such a Merced [ __ ] were they
arguing and fighting each other no he
was great his dad my mom I don't know
why they broke up
my mom was a side [ __ ] for a minute
yeah so pretty much what happened sorry
Mom
I'm just gonna say oh hey you're old
enough I'm gonna smoke a joint keep
continuing so
prison bird
was stalking my mom found her by the
pool my dad was there and then he had a
duffel bag right and he walked up and
dropped it and it just sounded like a
ton of metal like a ton of heavy metal
dropped it next to my dad and just
started circling him like a shark like
so scary in my dad my dad just went yep
yep that's what you do when a shark's
around you didn't even stand up no and
then my mom had to like start fighting
with me wait is that why my mom broke up
with your dad yes yes she was
she was like you didn't die for me you
suck and then and then she found out she
was pregnant and she was like no no this
stupid guy has my oh my God remember I
told you my mom was on some high
schooler [ __ ] that is some high school
[ __ ] to the team dude so I there's like
a thin chance I was born like
legitimately saying she broke up with
your dad because Prison bird scared him
yeah trumped him in front of her she
didn't tell me that she said that his
dad scared prison bird off again nope
bull [ __ ]
now I know the story you don't yeah I
didn't actually see any of this I was
not even born okay yeah yeah
what happened was my mom was like ew
that sucks you're and then broke up with
him then she had to go to court for
prison bird like because she um he was
like I'm gonna kill Shireen he was like
I'm gonna kill her and then oh yeah he
said he's threatened to yeah so he would
have never laid a finger on he was
twisting exactly exactly he would have
shot himself in the [ __ ] head before
he hit myself yeah yeah he was he he
knew also also we might have to bleach
some [ __ ] out these fools are laughing
over here this was over here saying the
dumbest unpolitically correct [ __ ] on
the show knows the [ __ ] show on
podcast knows we can't say that [ __ ]
we'll bleep it keep going continue
you're talking about Rocco yeah okay so
so catch it in the edit yeah yeah yeah
just wrong so they were in court my mom
said something about like prison bird
doing like saying she he was gonna kill
Shireen and then
he was going to go back to prison and
then my dad showed up
to court
to also plead about prison bird testify
that was the last time she saw him and
then like two weeks later she found out
she was pregnant and then she was like
no oh my God
but she she's with him again a couple
months later when she was pregnant they
were like working it out because he has
a little he has older brother
this is what happened okay
he was like two years old is my like my
son as I was growing I raised his
[ __ ] kid and every no matter what was
going on right
my mom and his dad started they were
done not [ __ ] with each other no more
he's like two years old
he signed his rights over so you know to
pay child support nowhere damn but my
mom's a [ __ ] so it's not I know it's
not the way it went down I didn't know
that's how that worked yeah if you don't
if you just signed the rights away my
mom said you don't have to pay me you
just don't you don't have to see him
anymore just leave us alone type [ __ ]
but I think she was doing some spite
[ __ ] because he went back with his wife
I don't know Mom don't get [ __ ] mad
in the chat God damn I don't miss this
type of [ __ ] oh my God but this is what
happened he did that and all I thought
was I'm
your [ __ ] ass when I see you because
I'm [ __ ] 16 at the time like I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you my little
brother's looking for you like looking
up like where's my [ __ ] Dad I'm gonna
kill you like I was so upset can because
he has a brother two years older than
him that he takes care of I drop him off
at school and see that [ __ ] kid he
saw his dad dropping off his brother and
didn't even acknowledge Him yeah this
this is normal I like a lot of kids
going through this [ __ ] I'm sorry you
had to go through this April went
through this [ __ ] with her so when my
Grandpa died when my Grandpa died uh at
the funeral this [ __ ] showed up
to the funeral because his dad and my
grandpa were homies they're Uninvited
but then again it's like you know it's a
funeral my grandpa you were friends I
get it now that I'm older I'm dumb but
he walked in and I [ __ ] loked up on
his ass and he [ __ ] shook in his
boots and he was with his kid his only
reason I didn't [ __ ] lay into him
because I just want to beat the [ __ ] out
of him I [ __ ] hate him I don't like
him he's a piece of [ __ ] person
and you didn't have a [ __ ] dad
growing up so I was like it really
pissed me the [ __ ] off this is the same
[ __ ] town and it's just like I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you so like five
years in a row I try to beat the [ __ ]
out of this man I never really talked
about it openly but it's over now so I'm
not gonna get in trouble so I try to
catch him everywhere Marty 16 17 18 so
when I was 20 21 every time's got his
[ __ ] kid with him so I couldn't do it
and but I remember I was like 17 walking
down Target I dropped all my [ __ ] I'm
like here it is yes
yeah today's the [ __ ] day because
he's
he's big [ __ ] out but I'm gonna bite his
chest or kill him I'm gonna do something
I'm so upset
I'm like [ __ ] yeah I started picking my
pants up and he looked at me and he just
stops and like puts his head down and
I'm like dude I kind of feel bad you're
scared and then boom right behind the
shopping cart his kid comes out I'm like
[ __ ]
damn it but he's walking down the aisle
he's like talking to his kid I think
he's like yo if something happens just
walk to the front I think that's what he
was getting ready for like oh damn
Thomas finally caught me but I caught
his ass at Walmart three separate
[ __ ] times oh my God that's how you
know you're in a small ass town you keep
catching [ __ ] beef and they're
catching him dude
and then when I was like 24 I saw him
and I went you know what bro
Rocko's fine without you bro it's fine
that's when I stopped caring and then I
saw him at a car meet and went but she
walked around with that for years yeah
I've never want to beat someone's ass
worse in my [ __ ] life
ever just want to kill him that's good
back then now it's fine this was tall
he's fine
so has that relationship improved
with my dad uh-huh no damn well
uh yeah like five months longer than me
Rosie so that's basically your whole
life well not like half your life until
he was yeah since he was like six since
fourth grade he moved to Madera because
eight yeah we moved okay for him and
they've always had like a healthy
relationship right yeah yeah he's cool
he's full of cheese and she got him
credit cards and like they can build his
credit got him a car he's an actual dad
he's like really really good because he
was like
uh Finance like super big like that was
his job for years so he's like good yes
and when they moved down good I'm gonna
him and Tony that was just here we're
all gonna set up this thing and he's
gonna start running this business for
him and they're gonna move down here and
also do the nail shop he's so he's one
of the only boyfriends my mom's ever had
I'm like I [ __ ] with you whether or not
you chill with my mother is that when
you started to feel like
your mom's starting to get her [ __ ]
together well that and I felt like I
didn't have to worry about this
[ __ ] 24 7. because I was so poor
in everything but every money I had I
was buying this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'd
rather be times and be like [ __ ] I'm so
broke now I bought this [ __ ]
like 90 worth of toys but back then 90
meant everything yeah
but you know what I mean like and plus
his grandma and grandpa my Grandma and
Grandpa are dead yeah his grandma
grandpa they don't exist they don't talk
to his dad it's just my mom but I gained
a grandma and grandpa yeah I met when he
met Zeke my mom's boyfriend now his
parents so now he does have a grandma
grandpa and they're so cool yeah they're
[ __ ] awesome they're super cool so
that's why you can see Cadets and all
that yeah my grandpa's a CEO in the
secret program
wait hold on say it again my grandpa is
a CEO in the sea Cadet program so he
like is the main what is the secret so
secret that's just like Navy stuff but
for kids so and then if you rank up
enough and you're in and you're an E3
once you are 18 and you go into like the
actual Navy when you get out of boot
camp you can instantly be uh I think a
private it's like college prep classes
but for the military yes yeah I did it I
did I shaved my head four times with the
boot camp over and over again
it was good for me it was very good for
me describe was it was it did they make
it into like a hell for you guys or was
it um it wasn't like awful but you can't
decide
oh yeah that was bad we we had to Camp
up in the mountains and they were like
you have this box survive yeah also eat
these frog legs yeah let these kids off
in the woods I was so [ __ ] nervous
for this video yeah and then and then
the best part so we had to stay up at
night or two people at a time because
there's Bears so hey if you hear bear
here's the bear mace keep everyone else
safe [ __ ] nervous because he couldn't
have a phone was like waiting for I had
a phone no service was there adults with
you guys there was no there's adults
with us yeah like everyone is there Boy
Scout [ __ ] though yeah yeah but like
crazier the danger was real yeah and at
one one night I just stayed up the
entire night I was like I'm not I'm not
going to bed what was an average day
like were you out with it it was it was
like you wake up it was so sick you wake
up and it's like you can smell the fresh
Forest air and then we like get out of
our tents and you have to like stand and
then they do the little dender and then
you can start walking around are they
screaming at you and be an [ __ ] no no
that's at boot camp at boot camp it's
bad like so there's Leaguer which is
like for the kids
so like when I went in it I was a
Leaguer because I wasn't old enough to
be a recruit yet so I had to do Leaguer
training so I could be a recruit and
then I had to do recruit training and
then I did um
uh medical training like the special
trainings and um Leaguer super easy they
do yell at you and stuff like they teach
you you had to like do your marches I
learned the entire like alphabet like
alpha bravo back that stuff learned it
all super good like they're they're
really good at their program but
recruit trainings bad it's not like as
bad as the actual Navy but they they
scare you they definitely scare you to
wake up and they're just banging on
stuff and like shaking you and then it's
like all right go run two miles we're
gonna do push-ups until all of you are
crying and then when someone messes up
you all have to do it together it's it's
awful but
that's I fell in love with fried eggs
they're they're like good chefs fried
eggs fried eggs I've never had one
before Friday my mind went to [ __ ]
data and Craig yeah it's the first thing
I thought was on the bench it's the
first thing yeah no but they had they
had really good food there that was it
it was most of the kids there in trouble
or at risk no no no no there's like a
few like maybe one or two that were like
we're bad kids but they're they're cool
they're not like bad bad kids they just
like they smoked weed
you're going to the Navy but uh they're
all cool like everyone was super cool
but I think it's because we all had to
deal with it together that made it fun
but the worst part was mother would Mom
yeah Mom we would go the way he said
that sounded like yeah it's not it
wasn't that bad
we would I I had to go on the weekends
and I had to be there at like six in the
morning she was late
well we weren't ever really late it was
I had to eat before let's get McDonald's
and then right when I get there go run a
mile every time I would vomit I'd throw
up all the McDonald's have to wait till
three to eat and just be like oh all I
heard was my mom made me McDonald's and
then I wouldn't be complaining but yes I
understand why you throw up I was like I
need I need to eat something I'm hungry
were you highly aware that Thomas the
scenario growing up was completely
different
um I wasn't super aware but like once I
had an age and I started watching and
stuff I was like dude mom used to be a
Monster yeah Mom was so crowned out in
the videos yes sir like I didn't know
you can [ __ ] on your mom to him at all
no no no no no no no no no no he's got
to live with her I don't want him he
kept up her cool image she's she's
really cool she's like yeah right but I
mean like you had so much resentment
that I'm it's no enough not resentment
no never it was the resentment was
remember when you told when I was like
yo is it you're gonna am I gonna like
run away or is this guy leaving
and she didn't say a word and I went
earwhack and that's the only thing that
pisses me off to this day I was like
please stop bringing [ __ ] dudes here
my little brother's one year old and
he's meeting new [ __ ] dudes every
week that you're you're trying to date
because you're in your 30s you got
Facebook and [ __ ] so you're like dating
that's what my you know can you just go
on a date I'm like I'll watch him just
go on a date with the guys stop [ __ ]
bringing him to the house it's bugging
the [ __ ] out of me meeting all these
random people
and then The dude walked in they go
[ __ ] we just talked about this last
night
come on I'm like I'm gonna go I'm gonna
just leave or you can ask him to go and
she didn't say a word and I went damn
all right I'm out and I left and that's
when the me and my mom's list should
change completely your entire reason
baby boy yeah I it stopped right then
and there I went
I don't appreciate you as much as I did
anymore and I don't respect you as I did
and now I'm leaving and that's when I
was 15 I moved to orient all that [ __ ]
happened
because people before that me my mom
were best [ __ ] homies it was weird
how [ __ ] close you were but that [ __ ]
bugged me so you were close despite all
the I mean all we ever hear about is how
mean she was how yeah she used to be the
only person I had
yeah it's also fun to touch on the bad
things yeah it's fun yeah my mom was so
sick sounded [ __ ] weird fun to touch
on the bad things sorry when you said
like what oh talk about them yes that's
a good point yeah yeah highlight though
it's like yeah you don't you don't you
don't you're never like dude she was so
cool I mean she was like I [ __ ] feel
that you know yeah
she did this and this and this and this
but it doesn't mean that she wasn't like
beating [ __ ]
or something
she's still a nice person my mom was
also bipolar and [ __ ] like depressed
as a kid I found out that she told me
later so maybe like us asking for stuff
while she's going through a [ __ ]
moment wasn't the best also I'm a kid
being be cool I didn't know yeah but
yeah now that I'm older it's not her
fault she was a kid too trying to
grow up and also these kids yeah so
that's why I don't hold any of the
hungry [ __ ] against her and being on
meth hey man dude do your thing it's
that thing that bugged me because it's
like yo you're of age you're not on
drugs anymore I'm of age to drive and
you did
um
that's when I went
ah
decided to [ __ ] with her for like nine
years damn yeah
me and her just had a horrible
relationship you were like uh when was
that 17 I was 15 16 oh okay well when
she punched me is full force in the
[ __ ] face because I didn't mow the
lawn because it was broken
I tried I'm not a mechanic and then your
dad came down and chased you around
yeah damn and you know all about the
story yeah I've watched all the stories
multiple times
so that's how that's why he doesn't know
about my mom being crazy as a kid only
from the stories or else he would have
never known exactly
like I learned the past of my mom
through him well there's been times
where Mom says Rocco three times and I'm
like
[ __ ] up I'm like
my mom's just a pushover now
one and a half times back then I would
have got [ __ ] my ass beat get up a
second she says something to you yeah
but it'll be like three times and he's
like oh man
it's like this line didn't attack this
deer
uh-huh here he used to attack the deer
for nothing and now it's just a
vegetarian that's just that's how I feel
it made me think of the UFC last night
on you so bad what sorry that [ __ ]
Cas mat whatever his name is you watched
the fight last night yeah I watched him
but I don't know who was who it was like
a dinosaur in an antelope situation he
wasn't watching [ __ ] I was just gotten
this weight so bad when he came out
oh yes yes that was different that was
[ __ ] up that was [ __ ] up that was
like a mauling yeah like anyways yeah
sorry guys UFC UFC I love it um so yeah
Rocco did not know about my mom because
of that
but then again I mean like she's cool
she's cool now she's tripping yeah she's
[ __ ] awesome I mean she's great now
like I I almost I don't want to have
kids because I'm like I can't do it like
my mom did whoa yeah I don't raise kids
yeah like I don't because I'm like the
way Mom whatever she did she did it so
good
she did it really good you guys turned
out great what do you mean though like I
feel like I can't replicate the way she
raised me I feel like I don't want to
have a kid unless they're like me if
that makes sense you do it your way you
look at what she did right yeah that's
that's true but that's why you're not so
good that's why because I used to check
him at like 2
2
3
check his ass like an adult that was
rude uh do these things you don't do it
because this this and this and if I you
felt like that wouldn't you feel bad
so that's why he's a nice person since
he's a kid like stop that right now this
is why because I never baby talk this
[ __ ] life no no my mom's the
same way stop you hold the door open
that's a [ __ ] old woman that old
woman has a pain you hold the door of
this why this why this why boom big on
respect
forever and once you're polite
respectful everything else is easy
you know what I'm saying because you're
not a piece of [ __ ] damn so hold on so
when you went to Portland that was the
first time you kind of
was gone from him yeah when was that you
were like a year and a half oh and I
left for like six months
okay in my mind you were there longer
than six months no no and then I came
back for a year I was gone for a year
after the six months and I came back for
a year after high school and [ __ ] was
still crazy
with my mom at all I lived with my
grandpa I didn't even lose my mom I
never moved back with my mom
yeah then you didn't get back with your
mom so you're with Rosie and you did the
mushroom so that was that was 23.
okay so five years
well 60 to 23 70 years I've had enough
over there in the slightest well from 18
to 19 like a like five months in there
we were cool did that randomly from
seeing Rocco though
um
there's a long story probably don't want
to get into it crazy you should probably
get pissed
well no we talked about it I was like yo
one time mom I was plotting I'm like how
could I kill oh yeah yeah this is why
yeah I was like how can I kill my mom
without anybody knowing I don't feel bad
that's what I thought like and then I
went
I felt like that was disgusting Thomas
well she told me I can't see him no more
because I disrespected her and went
[ __ ] I told him I'll [ __ ] kill you
and then now they think about it if my
son said that it'd be like
I'm probably in the wrong here my nice
ass son said I'll murder you and end
your life sorry guys I know I said to my
mom it's Blasphemous and [ __ ]
but don't try to do that [ __ ] yeah it's
weird right a weird weird thing to do
anyway she was just mad at the moment
she just said it
it was a it was a small amount of time
she never kept him from me ever it never
worked I told her like [ __ ] I already
called the lawyer siblings rights I have
them because there's a such thing as
that that's a thing I went through all
his shell is [ __ ] pissed yeah what is
that what does that mean you have
allowed to see him like a father can
siblings have legal rights to each other
I'm over eat
I talk to I talk to somebody at this at
the same yeah [ __ ] though [ __ ] no
gotta be something man and during that
time frame did you did I don't even
remember anything
in my first memories were in Hawaii yeah
he was a little kid still like I turned
conscious in Hawaii yeah I would just
watch him here and there but I was
selling packs I was in college yeah so
it wasn't like I was like Mom can I come
watch the baby you know I was [ __ ]
busy doing [ __ ] but every chance I could
I could go I would see him it's not like
I was not let's see he's an old brother
yeah once he was in school I was the one
picking him up all the time I wasn't
dropping off I was just pick him up
because my mom was doing nails
I was picking them up for like three
years straight I remember that that's
one cool toy in the toy shop or the nail
shop there's a little robot I don't
remember nail shop sucks he grew up in
nail shop I grew up in no shot it
[ __ ] sucked I liked it I thought it
was cool do they have to smell you got
the nice nail shops that's true mom was
working to not mom was trying to come up
on the first one it was boring it wasn't
even TV in that [ __ ] I was just sitting
there as a kid's [ __ ] pissed yeah at
some point I had GTA 5. yeah that was
tight yeah you're a bomb I just said
shut the [ __ ] up yeah it was sick
my middle school was like a walk away
from the shop so I would just walk there
and play GTA until she was done and go
home this is over also there was a
McDonald's inside there was a red onion
right next door oh that's right Madera
they gave me free food I cleaned I
sweeped for them you want a free Burger
yes I do restaurant next door would give
him [ __ ] if you just speaking Yeah they
liked me a little side tangent on this
while we're talking about GTA you're a
gamer yes real quick in the midst of
this story
top three lifetime games
did you see the notes no I wrote that in
oh no [ __ ]
that's a hard question it's great I have
to I have to say Minecraft it's like
generational favorite [ __ ] you it's
not like I play like it's my favorite
thing but like it's so good like you can
do anything and throughout my entire
life I've been playing Minecraft did you
watch the hacks episode are you up on
optic gaming and all that I I've never
seen it until the podcast you said that
too yeah and he knows video games and
he's like he's the best man that ever
existed yeah it's it's it's good and
then even in comparison to all your VR
[ __ ] it just it doesn't compare you can
do anything like you can live a life you
can mod it like better
I don't think so keep going better you
can build and every time he's like I'm
built alive and go do it in [ __ ]
person he was mowing the lawn in
Minecraft know what you [ __ ] how
I watched you do some yard work dumb
[ __ ] and I was like stop you got beat up
over that shirt
mow the lawn in Minecraft it shows how
little I know were you washing dishes or
making burritos none
there's a game where you just make
burritos you were a chef that's that
Minecraft no that's VR
so even worse
and you're the only human in the entire
world is made of robots and they ask for
weird stuff like give me a hot dog with
toothpaste on it okay
I don't play much my favorite VR game is
boneworks it's perfect it's physics
that's the guy I met hey you're crazy
and I was buying a VR headset and then
right in front of us some guys flew by
and Rocco was like
it's the YouTubers he watches yeah it's
the bone digital oh yeah yeah there's a
new there's a new boneworks game coming
out and they were the developers were
there and I talked to one of them yeah
you just saw a little scooter and he was
like where where bone Labs I just throw
it off into the distance and I was like
no way because he watches these
YouTubers you see that that robot that
was shooting the targets and they were
smacking yeah and then it turns on them
it turns on him it was a fake video
you've probably seen it on privacy on
Twitter it's fake it's these guys CGI
but they wrote it
and then these two dudes rode by I'm
like oh go out doctor damn if they're
[ __ ] you [ __ ] lit no they they
were super nice I didn't get to talk to
them but they're very nice people like
they're super cool they're nerds so
they're just like
but that's they're just cool yeah that's
one thing it's like yo at first any
YouTubers out there and if you ever meet
a fan you better be [ __ ] nice
because it might be something someone
else knows and I will [ __ ] [ __ ] on
you forever if you're not nice yeah you
don't want it lifetime subscriptions
getting [ __ ] on on the podcast for real
yeah and I was waiting for him like were
they cool he's like yeah it was cool
like all right good
all right good right because I [ __ ]
hate people dude you know I shouldn't
have said like that I hate Dickens it
could have gone a different way yeah
[ __ ] way don't Bret Farm anybody
around me I'll [ __ ] let you have it
yeah so we saw that the [ __ ] video
games of VR he's so into VR I get sick
oh I talked about it I'm sorry where I
was Spider-Man and I was stabbing a guy
through the mouth sad you do [ __ ] like
that or okay is that like your primary
thing you're walking around you're just
like um popping heads off it's it's more
I can do whatever I want so there's like
a I can mod it too so I'll normally like
if I'm going to play VR I'll look at
some mods first and then I'll test some
mods out play around with them for like
an hour or two reading work any of this
is so like boneworks based game there's
just like normal guns normal enemies I
can add in whatever enemy I want I can
add in mods so like
my favorite monster Spider-Man yeah yeah
a little Chucky and he makes Chucky and
then he's like ah like like they're
actual it's like having a dream but
really cool you have like super strength
and like my favorite mods of Spider-Man
mod because you can literally just go
and swing everywhere yourself around you
can like grab people and like it's so
fun it's cool so blade and sorcery is
like slicing people up but you also are
like a mage it's so sick that one's
really fun but boneworks is like perfect
I got sick I placed for 10 minutes I'm
like this is amazing I'm a night slice
of [ __ ] I got yeah some emotion
yeah you can be you can be John Wick
with Spider-Man webs with a gravity gun
like oh it's you can smoke in a blunt
it's crazy because you can do anything
what's so fun is this stupid ass
question is this on a TV like what is it
well you you can watch me play yeah so I
I put on the headset and then the game
is playing on the monitor but I can see
see it we got to do this next time
oh no
here I don't have the valve you brought
the valve I don't we'd have to like we'd
have to like drill into the ceiling I
thought you said it like a connoisseur
like
it's not in mind there's like sensors on
the walls I I wasn't going Oh I thought
you brought all that no I brought I
brought the Oculus box case I thought
that's what it was no it's all good um
okay so those are your video games
so so Minecraft boneworks
GTA like it's just good it's good now I
heard they just officially announced
that they're discontinuing GTA 5. what
they just say goodbye to it yeah yeah so
what does that mean they're no longer
gonna make updates yeah they're probably
not going to update it and they might
shut down online at some point and I am
five years they're gonna keep it out and
they're gonna keep it up but they're
probably gonna start shutting it down
and move all the servers to GTA 6. and
you're heavy into the like RP and all
that I've never been able to figure out
the mods for GTA 5. I don't know why I
think I'm just doing it wrong I've just
watched so many videos I can't figure
out how to get into the servers it's
annoying Omar probably does yeah when
you sit down to play uh does anybody sit
down and play just do the [ __ ]
Missions at this point or is it um yeah
well online is very fun and also gives
you New Missions everyone is modding it
and like okay like not modding it
hacking it where you just like have a
big list and oh I'm Invincible oh all my
grenades shoot like Yeah it's annoying
so I had to download the hacks so I
could just survive because people are
just coming around with compressors and
blowing you up non-stop [ __ ] nerds
but it's it's so fun like it's the the
New Missions they're cool and the new
cars are really cool job simulator
that's a [ __ ] job I don't
[Music]
well the Navy stuff and then I like
helped my dad out a lot yeah he's just
having like a job to clock in or
anything then you just graduated high
school right yeah nice yeah plus there's
quarantine you can't really have a job
yeah I got I got my my last like two and
a half years of school taken away didn't
get to do anything I was a freshman then
like three minutes into being a
sophomore they're like bye forever
kind of awesome
but at the same time I never had
experienced that and with phones and
like the fear of missing out being
stronger than ever before because of
phones yeah I could see how kids just
went into a depression of like I can't
see anybody yeah it was awful I just got
a new school clothes to sit in my house
but the best part my best friend Cody
lived a block away from me we could walk
to each other's house
but did that make doing the actual
School harder or easier I have never
done homework I do it in class that's my
whole you the second you hand me the
paper I'll do it right there it's on my
online [ __ ] though I know but the second
I got to online it was awful like I had
never done homework so the second
they're like do it at home I was like oh
what do you mean do it at home so I like
I dropped out of that high school went
to the credit High School where you just
do them credits at a time they give you
packets I was like this is easier for my
brand and then at some point when
schools open back up there's one in
Madera so I would just I went there for
like two or three weeks finished
everything I was still like a sophomore
and I finished from sophomore all the
way to senior year in like three weeks
so I was just like because I'm good I'm
in once I'm in class like in a room I
can do it I just have to be somewhere to
do this specific thing options yeah I
have a amazing computer you think I'm
gonna do this history assignment shut up
yeah go away there's too many
distractions at your house this video
exactly and then lambo's like yeah
almost dog yeah keep that don't let that
go though exactly like when I get to
where I'm going the yeah it's done and
when I leave then I yeah it so that's
why I like when I'm here comments are
way harder somebody
yeah I'm in L.A it's easier when I'm at
home and I can like sit down in my chair
but all right all he does is [ __ ] VR
I mean then play video games in my house
has taken advantage of a photographer I
have stopped
L.A I was playing heavy for like a week
or two people just say Rocco has about 5
000 photos circulating out Instagram the
push to his Instagram has been going
crazy this past couple months Justin
Boyd who rolled these monstrous
Joy beautiful joints that we're
featuring on today's episode coming with
the amazing photography fingers with his
dainty fingers little dainty camera
fingers I'm six four a little baby hands
he wrote These with his toes he did he
did that's why I keep hitting like this
guys we all know going into sexual
situations you want to be feeling
confident feeling yourself feeling good
going into it not leaving you and your
partner all bummed out not having a good
time bluetooth.com to the rescue
Bluetooth is an online service and has
the same active ingredients as Cialis or
Viagra except it's in chewable form and
it costs way less Bluetooth tablets are
helping guys combat all forms of Ed walk
around with the best hardest strongest
most competent erections in the history
of all men and because Bluetooth is an
online prescription service there's no
waiting in line at the pharmacy might
run into somebody you know no going to
the doctor visits talking to a doctor
about this because most people don't
want to talk about no big boxes to say
blue shoes showing up at your door it's
a discreet packaging process is simple
at bluetooth.com we sign you up online
they link you up with their licensed
medical providers and get you registered
for your prescription once you're
approved you're getting your
prescription within the next few days
best part is it's all done online and
earlier when I said it's a fraction of
the cost it's so much cheaper that's
because Bluetooth is made here in
America and it's right for the
manufacturer to your door try out blue
shoe for free just pay the five dollars
for shipping go to bluetooth.com use
code dope at checkout so go to
bluetooth.com use code dope and that's
your first month of treatment for free
welcome to fresh ball fall we're sipping
cider we're trimming our balls with the
freshness so whether you're new to
manscape or you've been cleaning up for
a long time guys Platinum package 4.0
has every single thing you can need for
Hygiene coming new we got the 10 part
Platinum package which is everything we
previously knew from the performance
package plus some added and showered
goodies and bonus extra stuff the
lawnmower 4.0 guys you've heard about it
many times the the weed whacker nose
hair trimmer ear hair trimmer remember
skin safe the proprietary technology for
manscapes is gonna make sure you're not
slicing yourself open so whether it's
the lawnmower or the weed whacker just
to let you guys know they are both
waterproof guys we got the Ultra Premium
body wash the Ultra Premium two in one
shampoo and conditioner new for
manscapes elevating the entire shower
experience aluminum-free premium
deodorant they have many things you
probably didn't know about so scroll the
site forgot the crop preserver ball
deodorant we got the crop toner ball
reviver to make sure your balls are
smelling as fresh as your pits with this
new premium deodorant coming from
manscapes go to manscape.com time right
now get 20 off plus free shipping with
code Yola again guys that's 20 off
remember at
www.manscape.com forward slash Yola
that's our code Yola at checkout 20 off
plus free shipping on anything you buy
once again guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
all right sorry where are we at video
games done yeah ready story I'm gonna
ask you a question
I'm asking you a question then you tell
me what happened okay
one time mom told me that you slapped a
girl in the [ __ ] face in line at
school and in line on the bus
wait in line or on the bus I don't
remember slapping someone in line but on
the bus I did
you hit two girls no the one was the one
that was a kindergartner when you were
in first grade I don't know I don't know
anything that's not what I swear I
didn't do anything you know I know
you've right here you have a tell and I
know you very well probably since birth
I know when you're [ __ ] lying so I
don't remember in line but I remember I
don't remember my very first birthday
but I do remember
um on the bus
on the bus
um she was making fun of my hair it
showed you right yeah I hated that he
hates Rocco talk I don't know I was I
was also like your body you're a baby
like shut up I'm not a taco like I was
just upset and she was making fun of my
hair I just died and I was like oh you
suck and I went that's how happy he full
four slapped her she started scream
crying okay don't go no in my brain my
brain is like completely like rearranged
the whole story so it might make it look
better for you yeah I know 100 in my
head I know I know I went and she did
this on the other side of the table or
on the other on the on the other seat
and then she got up and started
screaming that's I don't know I don't
really remember hit her she sat down to
hit herself hard in my head that's what
happened got you in my head I went ah
you suck and then she went down and
slapped herself what they told me was
that he hit her really hard and she
started screaming and crying she just
liked Rocco he didn't know that he was
[ __ ] six years old some girl making
fun of his hair
dude I have a history of slapping people
that's all I've ever done yeah I've
never gotten into a fight because it
ends with me slapping you one time and
then like ow hold on don't be going on I
have another question for you
we've talked about this on the podcast
I like movies and shows he likes movies
and shows I used to let him watch shows
because King of the Hill is soft that's
my purse yeah it's not crazy Family Guy
reference wild [ __ ] I think the hell is
a plot and it's somewhat yeah it's
pretty boring but it's funny yeah it's a
good show so he loves Bobby Hill because
Bobby Hill's a child he's looked up to
him like I looked Bart Simpson okay
kinda so in the episode we talked about
it that's my person I don't know you and
he kicks him in the dick
he did that to somebody at school do you
remember what happened and why I
remember I think I did it after I had
gotten detention
because we were like during like play
time we had to go sit against the cement
wall and I was like you want to see
something funny you you knew the kid no
but we were like both in detention
together sitting against the walls you
want to see something funny stand up
this is my purse I don't know you and I
kicked them
yeah this will try to tell me
that I don't know why we were fighting
uh-huh oh I don't remember you guys were
just bored I was walking by The Thorn
bushes the rose Thorn bushes on
my Ninja Turtles
walking from in front of Sheehy for
everyone to say I was walking in front
of she going away from the school to my
grandma dolores's house because that's
back when they're still
damn that's back on Grandpa's to live
there that's great I remember that house
I remember there was one time I got
really sick there and you came with
green Gatorade and I was like oh I don't
remember that it was like thundering
outside and I was vomiting wow Grandpa
was still alive yeah I remember another
time I was like really hot and I just
laid on the black tile in the hallway
and I was like oh it's so cold what the
[ __ ] is happening this is like my slight
memories of like do you remember I
remember from that house okay I got you
George Lopez on the TV while I was
asleep and seeing the big Shadow
it's a good Storyteller no you wake you
wake up to that song sweating yeah like
sweating just like what's happening yeah
like you're afraid for some reason that
song there's something in that song oh
[ __ ] you're afraid of the house no The
George Lopez song when that song plays
and you wake up from it you're like
startled isn't that isn't the theme song
War
saying War gives you this call when when
it's paired with George Lopez and he's
doing the thing where he's just floating
in the air
like that it yeah it's it's a weird
feeling everyone can 100 relate to that
as a child yeah no no there's definitely
people who are going to relate to that
I'm gonna say I I can guarantee you not
one person I've seen it so many times
says that it makes them feel demonic oh
I said demonic what did you say it's
just it's just like you get a weird
feeling you wake up like huh like
sweating for some reason okay
when I used to watch Family Matters and
when I used to wake me up I would be
[ __ ] so I understand
yeah
I'd be [ __ ] during Family Man
without fail without fail I'd be I'd be
duking it up yeah that's all I remember
until I was 26 years old that's all I
remember from that house so uh you
slapped a kid in the [ __ ] face kicked
him in the dick you're a cool kid
[Laughter]
that was a good one so my next question
you kind of answered have you ever been
in a fight not in like an actual like
I've never gotten punched in the face
nope you ever punched anybody I got I've
got punching like the stomach by who
some kid named Moth his name's moth moth
no it's not his name is Moth
his sister's name is asthma
hey let's not be putting these
[ __ ] on blast too let's not put
them on blast too hard with these whack
ass names bad names that's not real 100
real why are you put you in the stomach
when it was like the last like the the
second to last day of school and we were
staying Wednesday what's what grade uh
sixth grade
yeah no I've never been in a fight in
high school it was all it was all from
sixth grade in the stomach or we were
like standing and then he like kept
bumping into me or like we kept bumping
into each other and then he was like
stop and he pushed me I was like don't
push me again and he pushed me again and
he punched me in the stomach and then I
slapped him across the face and ran home
I ran out and just ran home because
school was about to end
up it works
it works so it's it's over once you
don't break your knuckles yeah and over
once you that's when it starts if you
slap me get ready I don't slammed into
the Earth I don't know what it is but
like as a kid you're tall as no I was a
child
still talk kid you slept slapped him in
his face
well I ran well slapped him I was like
I'm out of here who's on next it was the
last day of school it was like the
second to last day of school and then
when I got back because they were like
my the principal was like oh something
happened come back with your mom and
then my mom was like can you just like
suspend him for like the next two days
so he doesn't have to come back and then
he was like yeah okay but and then that
was it the end of sixth grade what about
seventh grade seventh grade there was
some kid no what about seventh grade
with this kid he never saw him again no
no we're gonna do a different different
Middle School oh sick and from 17.
moth out there you might have to be
careful for
wow but hold on he was a dick to you and
that's why yeah and he punched you in
the stomach he punched me in the stomach
okay
out there damn you let someone kick you
so that's crazy because I was like don't
push me again I know I pushed him and
then he kicked me and I was like his leg
up that high and you were like damn I
ain't gonna Dodge this I don't know I
don't really know what happened I just
remember being like dude and running
away but so somebody still owes you a
punch I'll beat the [ __ ] out of you man
this kid's parents
let that [ __ ] go and then he's adult now
another another time in sixth grade
before this event
um
some kid was running around in a circle
calling me like in a like actually like
circling me and I backhanded him
oh because you paint your nails yeah I
got him oh I got him right well because
I bit my nails really really bad and my
mom did nail so I was like if you do my
nails I won't I'll feel bad biting them
hmm he was saying
you're gay and I got him and I got him
and then that same kid like commented
some I had a YouTube channel when I was
little yeah I loved it that's right
that's right they kept he commented some
horrible stuff right when I left to go
watch an Iggy Pop concert with Mom here
in La so I just left he commented it so
I had to sit with it for like a week in
my stomach and I was just like Ugh
ruined my trip damn that sucks like
paragraphs
same kid didn't no I didn't know he did
wait hold on you found out yes no I I
got to school and I was like who did it
I asked like four people who did it
they're like it's just good it's this
kid so what happened without hesitation
I walked up to him and I slapped him to
the side
of course I could
as hard as I could
I could right in the ear and then he
like instantly dropped and started
crying I heard it I did pop his eardrum
he deserved it he deserved it my teacher
was like why did you do
did you get in trouble for popping his
ear my teacher was like why would you do
that and I showed her my phone with the
comments and she was like oh oh my God
go to go to the principal didn't wasn't
mad at me no one was mad at me you
deserved it but did he get in trouble
did you get in trouble I did go hospital
well it wasn't like that bad but it was
like it like rung his eardrum and he was
like ah remember that she's exaggerating
[ __ ] I thought you meant like he
was gushing no he wasn't gushing blood
but he was like he was crying he was
crying for like hours I think I messed
up his ear a little bit good [ __ ] him
and now so what happened he went to
school with him continuously
um he never messed with me again yeah
talk [ __ ] I slapped him two times I'd
stop too
um but now he's an awful person oh that
sucks no like an awful person
like probably don't even want to say it
he's a bad person Let It Go there's no
reason to bring up this naked ass [ __ ]
I'm negative [ __ ]
three people
got in the Wrath of the Palm damn so
you've never been in an actual no right
nope because like I don't want to fight
anyone I'm I don't want to fight you I
don't I don't want to fight you I was
also little in high school yeah I was
5'2 freshman year and then the next year
I was like five eleven yeah it was fast
damn
I'm just imagine like damn sucks yeah
I've never been in the fight
I was in sixth grade so in like seventh
grade some kid was like I had a notebook
that I like Drew in because I was really
good at drawing
and he came up and tried to rip it in
half yeah and I grabbed him by the
backpack and just like swung him around
and that was it
Jesus Christ
this Fool's [ __ ] dumb
making it harder for Marty you got a
three-year-older in the room that is
YouTube
no not even that Susan knows this
helps with YouTube comments
so it's not like he doesn't know these
things what what does that mean I want
to cut to the video that I showed you
the other day of the the dog on the the
other podcast remember that video I
showed you oh yeah it's not age
restricted it was these two dudes from
talking to podcasts
that's good
not age restricted poor dog not even age
restricted
[Music]
before we start I go hey
you didn't say nothing stupid
so I was wondering being the video
editor around here what did it feel like
modeling for your favorite brand dude it
was amazing like it's been my favorite
brand since like
seventh grade I saw some girl wearing
the purple rip into camo slides and I
was like those are sick with the little
flipping off I was like that's amazing
what brand is it rip a dip and I was
like I love it and then the next time I
went to L.A we went and I was like this
place is so cool and I'd love them since
then so cool I love their brand their
clothes are just like unique like they
don't do anything the same how would you
describe the look of their clothes to
somebody who hasn't seen it before
that's it's like edgy but it's not it's
just like they they push things a little
far everything they have is a joke and
it's silly and I love it but it's
colorful and done good yeah right and
they do like aliens yeah yeah yeah
cartoons not normal that's the cast name
yep
um rip and dip is what the brand we're
talking about love it so before we even
get into it and get in the comments and
everything when we show these uh doing
ribbon dips ever he's like do you know
the history behind the owner don't care
shut up don't care if you want to
comment that in the comments on this
video you're wasting your time yeah hey
if is this me are you doing that don't
even acknowledge it because we've talked
about it like 70 times I Googled it went
what's going on here I've Googled it
like four times nothing obviously he's a
police report about an argument and
people screaming at each other
what Google internet are you looking at
that you're not finding more stuff
because the I don't get too into it but
the owner and his girlfriend got in the
argument everybody's like he's gonna be
those are like ill I I can't even find
it on Google
4chan like thread it's crazy so long ago
so before we get into the river thing
because it's gonna be in the comments
four times you let your brother rep a
brand from a gun like shut up he just he
was 11. loved the colorful clothes it's
so cool favorite brand and now he gets a
model for him let him have it let him
have him stop so cool I just like model
it when I first like saw rip a dip
modeling wasn't even like something I
thought of no at all but I told you when
you were like what 12 years yeah and
then he started everything like I would
not be doing any of it if it wasn't for
him like we went and got Diamond clothes
and then we just oh my shout out to Omar
ratchets
you've been taking pictures since back
then yes
let's see yeah you got it I got it I got
it keep going okay dude I was a little
like I was a baby I wasn't a freshman
yeah I was still in like eighth grade
see one of the first pictures I ever
took of this crazy
she like pushed me to like start it
damn Thomas was just good at taking
pictures do you have the art do you have
any of the archives yeah you should show
him uh the young kid one the one on you
know which one I'm talking about baby yo
he looks like a [ __ ] little baby dog
he's little face but he's all sick all
this uh Diamond [ __ ] cause Omar that was
his other brand he loved before he ever
saw ribbon dip I love Diamond I go well
my friend works there and Omar's of the
man look at me look at his face that
doesn't even look child this was 2017.
little baby you look a lot more like
white boy as a little kid no 100 yeah
it's his hair now yeah a little white
kid
I'm a baby you look like a little ass
kid I was a child yeah all my I took all
these Thomas it's so good on the phone
we just went around and took pictures
they look good like look at my little
face look how small
look at my little face I was a child but
he's doing this little modeling she's
like that's so cool made me feel cool
yeah and then Omar's like yo here's the
diamond warehouse and I was like what I
like diamonds a lot I was like what grab
what and we just stacked this [ __ ]
fool up with so much gear it was so
tight it was from there I remember
saying I'm like I'm stoked to be in the
diamond yeah oh yeah like yo Rocco go
nuts it was it was really really cool it
was and I feel like that was like a
little Catalyst for me I like barely
started Sea Cadets then like that could
have gone two different ways I got I was
given two like different opportunities
yeah that's cool wild and then getting
to rip and dip so sick like I I can't
the feeling of like them texting me I
was like
just hurt
you know when I say things they happen
and they do they do happen I don't
understand how you do it I don't know
how he does it I just like I already
watched that movie
oh my God
it's the only explanation
is a nice person at work
[Music]
you know me very you know what the thing
is this is my 15 people that go see
it it's true God there's a pentagram
under his bed Jesus Christ no I don't
even have it I'm still waiting on a bed
frame what are you talking about it's on
under one part of my bed it's under the
floor under the part that dips and
breaks
shut up
[Music]
[Applause]
um
yeah this is freaking hilarious you know
what I'm saying we're talking about
Rocco modeling and all the diamond [ __ ]
taking all the pictures on the phone
I was gonna oh Diamond uh ribbon dip
yeah oh yeah you're not even high you
can't even help us get back on track I
like watching it what's up really cool
man yeah every once in a while how we
got to rip and it was like everything I
say is going to happen and yeah yeah
yeah that's what it was I was like oh
we're gonna call Omar and we're gonna
ask for uh to go to ribbon dip and I'm
gonna buy some stuff for him yeah yeah
yeah I I was like tripping like that's
the guy like he looks like a normal
person but I was like
oh my God
Tech decking with Thomas yeah right now
I was just doing Tech Decks of this dude
like 15 minutes
you know it's Tech Deck with that voice
type thing for a while yeah I remember
that while he was shopping yeah oh the
video dude and then and then they posted
me people shopping you're jumping ahead
hold on hold on I didn't know that was
the owner but I knew the second I bring
this fool in the way he looks and the
pants he had on I go
take a couple pictures of him in here
tag ribbon dip and they're going to ask
him to model and then he's going to get
a real modeling job from them and then
he's going to be in a magazine or a
billboard or some ad with him and I told
you that when we got in the cargo
Rockets that's going to happen we're
gonna do this this and this and about
three months he'll be in an ad he did
and it was like no less than a month
less than a month later
[Music]
and he hits up Omar like
yo who's that kid that your friend
Thomas brought in well that's a little
brother like yo what do you want to do
some pictures like [ __ ] yeah less than a
week later he hit us with that that's a
month later he was already coming back
down
that was so cool that was day one like
I've all like I just I love rip and dip
so like seeing that was like yeah you
saw the [ __ ] new collection that they
dropped on their website it's all the
Tim yeah it was coincidentally the 420
job not even on because when we went to
the photo shoot they're like here hold
this bomb like
with the bomb hold the bomb and then I
put it to your lip I'm like what no
I was there like dude this is crazy it
was weird but it was really cool though
and then they posted the whole and then
hold on and then they asked you to come
back and we did the real deal ribbon dip
one that was real studio and they had
some [ __ ] kid there that I'm like
that's not fair he looked fake you know
you look fake hey he looked like he was
like the perfect circle like you were
like you look at him like you have a
yellow penny board don't you look like a
sculpture if someone sculpted the
perfect California Surfer exactly yeah
that's how Russians see California [ __ ]
that kid was [ __ ] awesome super cool
super cool very cool kid he just just
started modeling he's like well bro I'm
just [ __ ] [ __ ] up I was like yeah
I don't care what the money it's like
ribbon dead like this guys this guy's
cool I [ __ ] with him say no man then he
showed me he's like
he's like oh I there's a video of went
viral he's like [ __ ] millions of
views on it he has a backflip and Slants
on his [ __ ] mouth
as a model bro
all right good for you but we got there
that's what rock was like
yeah I felt I felt weird I was like oh
no I have to actually kick it have you
ever watched any videos or had anybody
give you advice on how to pose no not
till after
for a couple minutes nothing
it's very uncomfortable like it's it's
it sounds like oh it's hard it's hard
you gotta like earn that tall streetwear
kid yeah I just look like you got to put
your hands in your pockets
have cool hair you did it done that's it
that's all you need is a tall streetwear
but when it comes to high fashion [ __ ]
like like his homie
uh shout out to Burberry once again
randomly his homie I was like this
high-ass kid he brings over my house
Trent a couple years ago random story
real quick he brings as high as
he's from the UK from Liverpool sounds
like a The Beatles
[Music]
hard to understand and I was like who is
this but he walked he goes
and he didn't know that Trent knew me
and he's a [ __ ] fan he's from the UK
so he was coming to stay at me I was
like
what the [ __ ] he walks in like that's
where we're staying and he said watches
my [ __ ] and Trent didn't know tell him
who we were staying at he's like my
friend I'm like yeah you could bring
your friend he's just a model kid and
we're getting high and all this he's
like yeah dude he's kind of embarrassed
about it he's like yeah model he's a
[ __ ] face of the Burberry campaign
tall ass Runway [ __ ] model he crushed
it when I Googled his name like give me
your last name so I can see I'm like
this is you oh my God that is you like
you just look high in my house right now
but holy [ __ ] we took a couple pictures
of him and pushed trees gear because I
just thought he was on Venice Beach
right on Santa Monica and the second the
camera came on that full change this
whole [ __ ] attitude just went and
started doing this potion like wow
that's why your model yeah you think
that shirt looks great the better it's
ever ever how we made it crazy we posted
it and then he goes
I don't think I could be modeling for
your weed shirts I just wanted the
shirts I cut my head a little I'm like
all right I will do that I'm like I want
that Gucci campaign
like what and that's what I saw I'm like
you're the face of purple are you piece
of [ __ ]
wow that's before I ever knew about
designer Brands I didn't know what
Burberry was I'm like wow is that
expensive or something that was still at
like the first apartment huh it's the
first apartment Wow first apartment
that's crazy yeah but you really it's on
you to make that [ __ ] look good like we
do have the best lens the best camera
yep best lighting do your job you and
it's a subtle thing like you're saying
he [ __ ] turned it on like yeah it was
quick the second he put the shirt on I
was like
yeah this will like [ __ ] it's
possible chain like yo you made our
shirt look [ __ ] hard and I didn't
I've never seen it before this is
[ __ ] six five six years ago I never
seen any model for real yeah it was
impressive yeah it was pretty [ __ ]
cool I feel like I still don't even have
it down like it's so difficult that's
because you don't practice enough you
don't do yourself reading nothing if you
had a camera like the camera I gave you
and you have somebody help you name
Marlin and you can just do your own
thing I've been trying to [ __ ] you I've
been trying to make this fool do his own
[ __ ] gave him a [ __ ] camera holding
the social media I'll help you post I'll
get you the brands I'll help you stop
being a lazy [ __ ] stop playing video
games and help me help you and that's
pretty much where we're at right now
thank you
he's not arguing I know he's not because
he knows he's got a lot going on I'm not
six two take advantage of it [ __ ] yeah
that's true oh [ __ ] all you
oh damn
average height of six four and a half
right now in this room Justin's helping
us out is it six four he's supposed to
six two this one's six one this was six
one [ __ ] you guys
hey I'm taller than the camera
and the Grim Gremlin yeah he's chilling
[ __ ] crushing it then [ __ ] you guys
use your advantage in your height in
your look
um like I was saying like I think with
enough work and enough effort and time
all right social media is hard well do
you have like somebody that you know
close that does social media that can
help you
yeah can I help grow your social media
and I hope you do stuff and get
streetwear do you know somebody that can
help you like get in the streetwear
brands might know some owners
this guy I'm trying my best to like
he'll move out here or something and
make it happen because you could be on a
billboard in five [ __ ] seconds I know
it like I said with rip and dip they
walked I might just show him I just did
that yeah they're like yeah that's
exactly what I knew what would happen
like it doesn't usually go like that no
but I knew it because I looked at him I
told you into 12 my yeah you can be
model you're gonna be fine are you a
very like aspirational person do you
want to go after all these things I do I
really like that's that'd be amazing but
it's like I I am I'm fumbling I do need
to be doing more I do but
there so now do it now that you're
graduated I mean what's the next chapter
your life look like ideally I don't know
that's the thing
all right so it sounds like you just
graduated high school you want to
breathe for a little bit but then you
want to come up with a plan I do really
good afternoon I do I really do because
if you could be a millionaire by 20 I
think you should [ __ ] go for it 100
yeah 100 you should go yeah that's not
an option for most kids whatsoever yeah
no I'm very lucky because of him like
you would have to crawl out of a hole
for their hole exactly he put me on a
pedestal so sad I don't think it's like
here
let's do something what do you want just
go for it the brand you guys talked
about rock has this little [ __ ]
clothing brand him and his homie Drew up
I think is [ __ ] sick and I think it's
cool as [ __ ] Rocco do it I think it's
[ __ ] tight the little thing you guys
Drew I'm like this is
all right where is this at yeah that's
easy something can be done right now I
think that could be cool you're younger
you're a different generation
you're not dumb
yeah yeah I think you got it future
looks pretty good for me yeah I think
it's I think it's they can think of God
right so that that's what I was thinking
I think you should be doing we'll figure
it out yeah figure it out actually that
that would be really cool
I don't know man you're making videos
with your homies that's oh yeah because
the kid was talking [ __ ] on your YouTube
if you type in he knows my name that's
what it's called type in He Knows My
Name on YouTube and it's this Fool's
video it's got how many views on it it's
564 000. it's got so many people and I'm
like views as a child maybe so this is
what really happens this is like right
before I started modeling so yeah little
kid me is like Optimus Prime this is
crazy and that got me a thousand
subscribers so I'm already monetized on
my channel
we're making yeah okay so we me and my
friends were all making a ton of videos
once we have like eight or it's gonna be
the Olympics and then everything is
going to lead up to the last one and
then we're gonna post all of them or
like he's been filming videos with his
homies it's been fun we went to um Magic
Mountain or Six Flags and then my
friends got five violently high and then
got on roller coasters
the whole way it was it was so funny
though they're just like with
schizophrenic looking just like
but in a funny way like they're they're
fine
he looks like he looked all diabetic
kid was actually diabetic and [ __ ]
sounds like a [ __ ] oh butane first
yes
what uh hold on sorry
the real story now that he's an adult
and I can say I think I might have told
him now that he's an adult the real
reason you got to meet Optimus Prime is
because I just sold drugs so this is
what happened
um I know this guy piece of [ __ ] I know
this guy that was on the World Series
winning Dodger team in the 80s like 85
or he said I don't know I don't watch
baseball but he was on that winning team
he got the ring he's like an old school
Dodger legend in the area he's still
around I won't say his name but you know
Dodge you know he is [ __ ] you
um
he's a real cool guy I thought super
cool at least up until this point super
cool guy no
and my little brother loves [ __ ]
Transformers and I know it it's just
Bumblebee's I still want to come around
[ __ ] I still want a Transformers I
want a yellow Camaro do anything you can
do and if I could do it as a kid I'm
like y'all [ __ ] try to find it try to
get it in because he's [ __ ] he's been
the best dude I mean I wasn't there I'm
like yo whatever I can get you I'll send
it
and this guy met him through OG
don't [ __ ] with him either anymore
anyway he's he's the guy he gets you any
tickets in the world he sees the X
Dodger play he's season tickets he's
that he sells tickets that's what he
does as a living and I tell him I'm
gonna go to universe
you buy tickets I go no I'm like also I
was like what are you trying to get me
you're a scammer a little bit so I know
you're a nice dude
and he goes I happen to know the guys
that do uh all the universal Optimus
Prime voice actors he's like yeah I know
the voice acting well shut the [ __ ] up
he goes yeah one of the voice actors is
no nephew had cancer and I got him to go
on this field at met at the Met Stadium
they did the whole thing for him you
have to throw a pitch so he's like he'll
do anything in the world for you forever
because I did that for him
in my head Thomas got Dodger guy to meet
this guy and the guy was like whoa the
Dodgers are cool whatever you want no
the Dodger guy had that guy in his
pocket forever because he did that thing
for his nephew so like any he's like any
favor you need at Universal just ask
I'll do it for the [ __ ] life so it's
like a nice thing the guy did for him
Dodger guy did a very nice thing for
that kid
so he's like don't worry I got you
Thomas you've been very nice to me he
smoked weeds I was always getting weed
getting them [ __ ] sacks for free and
[ __ ] tie it so that's why he's like
Thomas whatever you need like cool man
thank you he's a nicer older man super
cool I'm like yo my little brother loves
Optimus Prime we're going to the
universe he goes
I got just the guy he goes here here's a
number call this number number right
when you get inside right when you get
inside this is your parking pass this
isn't like what the [ __ ] oh yeah we got
backstage I didn't know what was going
on we get to Universal I paid in my
couple triple the price of the ticket
and he did it for me so it wasn't really
a favor but I paid for it but it's like
you would never be able to do it it was
basically the front of the line pass
gotcha what that happens I go downstairs
and go call this number I call this
number some guy with black eye paint
comes out like what the [ __ ] I'm at
Universal in the day with my little
brother whole like all right Rocco let's
do these rides I'm like let's just wait
he's like come on can we go on the ride
I'm like let's just wait for this guy
because he doesn't know what's going on
yeah he comes to me and he's like hey I
make I'm like what the [ __ ]
I'm like hey what's up man goes Hey so
uh so-and-so told me that nice to meet
you he did and then he told me about the
thing he did for his nephew he's like so
no matter what you need I got you he's
like he did that [ __ ] for me I'll never
forget it I'm like [ __ ] yeah cool and I
guess my little brother he goes oh it's
for a kid like oh even better watch this
and he comes out and starts holding our
hands walking us to the front skipping
every line so what do you want to ride
on the bottom level we went to every
ride like [ __ ] yeah as much as we
could Jurassic Park Jurassic Park the
mummy both of the Optimus Prime
Transformer stuff just wait on the line
went past and he was like what's up to
the front guard guy they let us right on
the front of the line pass we just
walked on and sat so waited for us I'm
like this guy is cool why is he got
horrible eye pain on weird and then he
goes all right so at two oh something
make sure you stand right there what's
your brother's name I'm like all right
cool
I hope they ever told the story and I'm
like whatever's gonna happen
love it
[Music]
so like yeah no the gates open yeah
yeah but there's a voice actor guy damn
there's a guy in the suit and the guy's
moving so as he does stuff into the
little girl hey little girl so he'll do
the voice but he's hella funny yeah
the guy with the eye makeup was Optimus
Prime okay he had the suit on yeah but
it's like a legit Universal giant suit
so he does this huge speech and then
he's like I can't think of anyone better
than my friend Rocco and he points that
rock and he calls him out I'm like what
the [ __ ] he knows
Rosie got him out I [ __ ] ripped the
[ __ ] out of my bomb real quick in the
car I was like I gotta [ __ ] smoke
before this doesn't be a long day and
then I'm sitting there like [ __ ] I'm
high oh and he calls Rocco's name so
come here and then the this people that
work there as prison guards but they're
army guys but they're Universal actors
like holding back Optimus Prime and like
all this is the sex it's all sick
decorated like Optimus Prime's layer
yeah
you know anyway type in He Knows My Name
he says Rocco's name and they let him go
through the gates and he's right in
front of his prime he gets his whole
speech to Rocco and Rocco's Forrest Gump
standing yeah it's like yeah he's like
yeah yeah do you know what happened to
the all-sparkers yeah I do and then he's
like all right Flex Scott would take
some pictures with me and he does this
whole speech that rock with him we're
gonna save the Universe I was so scared
I was like what is happening in front of
all these people I have no idea anything
cool is gonna happen yeah
where he gives a toy to his son and
jingle all the way here and he points
him out the crowd that's what he got to
expect yeah and I'm sitting there like
we did this this is crazy right and then
after the whole like five minute thing
happens I filmed the whole thing yeah
and that's what's on YouTube why he got
monetized I filmed this and he says he
knows my name because he didn't know why
I'm like whoa how did Optimus Prime know
you I didn't tell him
I just went Rocco how do you know I was
playing tickets
you know Optimus Prime hey dude I was
like what the [ __ ] you didn't tell me
we're gonna get mega times and just like
tell this whole story like yeah I guess
like you know
Let It Go Let It Go Let It Go he
uploaded to YouTube
I made 300 off that video that helped me
buy my guitar yeah isn't that [ __ ]
crazy but hold on sorry okay the way
you're telling the story is like it's
safe it was so cool everybody that
stopped to watch the show yeah there was
like 40 people dude all these kids are
like what the [ __ ] it's not fair but
Rocco's just standing there I'm like
good [ __ ] and I'm filming it and then
like five minutes later he comes out I'm
like dude thank you because I thought
you'd like that I'm like now I get the
eye makeup because you're in the suit
with the blacked out and then another
big oh yeah yeah yeah oh you're the
voice actor and then Rock was like huh I
know you I know you somebody goes oh do
you play OverWatch OverWatch
favorite character in OverWatch I was
playing heavy at the time
excitement and [ __ ] dying and this guy's
like oh I play Roadhouse and then
there's like voice quips that he does
oh my God
go and then as I showed you see I'm like
you smell like damn you're high he
looked like the character that Seth
Rogen plays in 40 year old virgin
with a curly hair big beard he looks
just like that like wow you do all these
voices then I asked him how did you get
into he's like honestly man I was just
like working he's like I gotta smoke a
little bit I was like I was just working
you know another state friends had a
nice voice and I could do crazy [ __ ]
yeah he was explaining to us how he does
it video games and crazy and Rocco
recognize his voice like you're from
somewhere why do I know he goes you ever
played OverWatch and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that and I was like yeah I
remember oh yeah that's a game you love
yeah I just got that game too for dude
he's like meeting the dude from his
[ __ ] video game Jesus Christ what a
day and he didn't know Optimus Prime was
if he thought it was Optimus Prime he's
a [ __ ] kid yeah
it was insane bro
and then for 30 minutes he took us to
every [ __ ] ride again
right back yeah I was like let's do it
again let's do it again I felt like he
was gonna do something horrible that's
why I thought my question about the
forehead this is I make him [ __ ] he's
like sorry man I can't get you the rides
upstairs I gotta stay down here because
you know it's like four escalators yeah
to get down we can't go 20 minutes that
way yeah I'm still working but the hell
am I said thank you so much thank you
your little brother save my number
anytime you come back text me I'm like
oh [ __ ] I just put him his name is like
I think it was like Bob Optimus Prime
wow how crazy is this and then um
the guy that got me the tickets super
cool started he burned OG burned OG's
friend I hooked him up because he's a
Dodger Legend I hooked up with my friend
guy in Merced that is a [ __ ] fanatic
hard-working ass dude in this full
condom for like five bands trying to say
he was giving him Dodger this Dodger
that exclusive this my friend's like oh
he was losing like you sell tickets I'll
buy anything and then he just never sent
it like me to Optimus I'm sitting here
hitting him I hit him up like what the
[ __ ] dude so that's why he's a piece of
[ __ ] I said and then
I don't know who you burned I'm not
gonna get too into it but it was getting
like some in the training day [ __ ] I'm
like this one's gonna get it who did he
burn oh for what I was like I'm worried
about five heads oh no but it wasn't my
money it's still bad for my friend in
Mercedes five thousand dollars is a lot
of money yeah and he burned my homie
dude that's why I was like he's a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] I hit him up like you're
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and I don't do
that I was pissed how are you gonna burn
my friend because he's a fan of you he
took advantage of him knowing that he's
a fan yeah you're supposed to get mad I
should have thought that was [ __ ]
heated and then OG was like
I don't care he's like he's gonna get it
but not for me and a bunch of [ __ ] was
going on and I pulled up on him in
traffic on the freeway once I went
I looked at him he looked at me and
[ __ ] changed lanes and went to a
different freeway and I'd never seen him
again bro he must be in another state
because I as soon as he saw me he went I
did I was gone forever dude he tried to
sell me his car the last time I saw him
it was like a 1950 something Thunderbird
and went whoa whoa you guys want to buy
it he goes
trade you this for gonna give me 5 000
right now 5 1000 did you steal this
what's wrong with it
he's a gambler he gambles like crazy
anyway piece of [ __ ] that's how you got
to meet Optimus Prime
all right from a [ __ ] shitty guy
that's how you met Optimus Prime that's
how you got monetized so shout out to
that [ __ ] what a long story sorry but
that's how it happened that's crazy
that's what happened in the back end all
right I just thought doctor childhood
we got a donut there it was over my
entire house it took me like three days
to eat I probably got three from it
Springfield they said you ever been to
Universal no you take all your [ __ ]
kids do it amazing dude Harry Potter
world's amazing they have Springfield so
sick and there you go to Krusty Burger
and I don't know because Christopher's
supposed to be bad but it was disgusting
it was authentic trash okay but
they have a squeaky Mart and inside it's
like the huge donuts that Homer eats but
it's oversized yeah it's like the pink
Donuts they come in a box
and he was like he was trying to [ __ ]
finish it I remember it was bigger this
whole chest it took me like little ass
kid that was crazy that was the first
apartment
I remember that Rosie met wrote me Rosie
started dating when he was just starting
school
so she watched his ass grow the [ __ ] out
yeah yeah school like first grade yeah
dude
damn that's crazy that's a long story
perspective I've heard kind of bits
yeah yeah you want me to my friends like
finally meeting you rock what they look
up like what the [ __ ] because he's like
your brother like expecting me your
height I'm the shortest person in the
family
all my aunts and uncles are six one it's
it skipped over our mom but I got it
from my dad his yes like I said it's
[ __ ] huge yeah but I'm the only one
that did not get tall it's weird
actually all my uncles you might still
shoot up this time honestly dude
I've been growing it's weird but I was
like 25 Rosie can vouch for me I [ __ ]
grew an inch
how is that possible when I saw myself
like 27. she's taller right and that's
when I went right did I just wanted that
Rose what the [ __ ] dude I got I was five
like eight five seven and a half I'm
like almost five nine
whoa I remember the last time I went to
the doctor and I was like 23 like you're
five seven I went damn I'm small like I
went recently five nine
take it I'll [ __ ] take it
it's not like other chiropractors Maybe
maybe dude damn are you 25. you were all
like decompressed Chiropractic for
[ __ ] 10 years man have you yeah on
and off I just forget to go and then I
was broke so I didn't go for a long time
I recently I've been going I'm just busy
I haven't been going
um real quick different story how long
are we at hour and a half perfect timing
guys it is Sunday four nights this
episode comes out tomorrow special
edition special edition while Rocco's in
town so we could watch the UFC last
night yeah sorry guys and then there's
football today so here we go this is
what I wanted to get out of here ready
I'm going to tell my perspective of the
story I want you guys over there to
listen to this story because it's
[ __ ] stupid and Preposterous
especially you train your good kick out
of this
Rocco's a straight edge I'm gonna tell
my perspective perspective and what I
expected what I got
and then you tell me what happened for
real let's do it my mom text me says Hey
first off mom if you're watching stop
texting me hey dot dot dot it's scary or
or she'll just go Rocco like what Thomas
doc like what happened who died [ __ ]
don't do that hey what's up Thomas hey
what's up Rocco don't just put Rocco
[ __ ] mom I call her every time like what
what are you doing like [ __ ] nothing
don't do that [ __ ] to me or every time I
FaceTime what's wrong like
calm down be positive so I'm gonna tell
this perspective and once she got she
told text me hey what what happened
so don't get upset
oh my God what
so don't get mad go shut the [ __ ] up and
tell me what happened what's wrong it's
like so your brother go what is wrong
how exactly like what's wrong what's
wrong it's like so he was at home gym I
go stop tell me that is okay first [ __ ]
and she's like so I walked into his room
and he was with Cody and I went
oh no
oh that's cool like she's damn I said
family brother I'm the only one having
kids I guess because she just left it
like I'm like wow oh Rocco yeah that's
cool so I caught him smoking we go Mom I
thought you said that Rocco when he were
like a together text better that's all I
kept thinking like is he okay oh okay
I'm the only one having kids again yeah
all right you went through the floor
right with the two emotions that's crazy
that's cool and it's like no we go oh oh
then what
and then she's like I caught him and
Cody
smoking a vape pen I go shut the [ __ ] up
he smoked in his room I did what an
idiot and I thought back one time I
smoked a drink
so I can you fell asleep yeah I fell
asleep it was worse but it was in the
day with a friend over under a blanket
they were smoking we weren't under
everything that's what mom's homie thank
you hold on let me get your perspective
that's what Mom told me so this is the
inconsistencies I'm saying my mom why'd
you even throw the blanket in there
so
you got caught smoking a vaping my mom
walked in the room there was smoke and
they tried to like get it away that's
not true either this is what my mom's
telling me hold on
[ __ ] ready what are they watching
my story time which episode
full circle wow Circle of Life very
unlucky circle of life now ready ready
you tell me what happened okay
walk in the door with Cody boom okay so
me and Cody we got a vape pen we're like
whoa okay let's try it you had just
released a video me and Cody were
watching your stuff for a while because
it was time the rapper still didn't
smoke yeah I was just like that's I like
Thomas it's really cool to see him doing
the stuff so me and Cody are like he
released a new video let's try it let's
watch this video so we were watching it
and then me and Cody are sitting on the
bed we're just watching it and trying
like smoking it and then Mom like burst
it she normally she knocks she burst in
and then Cody she knew something was up
Cody was on the left of the bed I was on
the right so Cody's closer to the door
the pen is on the bed in between us
so it's like there's you you can't
really see it from where she's at Cody
looks at my mom goes
and I was like oh
Cody
and my mom was like what was that and I
was like no no no
please were you scared like I was
terrified I was like well because I know
what she's been you're trying to be able
to do but before you found out about his
history with her did you have your own
fear of her
um I've always been afraid of my mom but
um
for like I'm not I've never been scared
of teachers none of that about my mom my
mom will beat me up and was your mom
ever suspicious of you or like popping
and thinking you're doing [ __ ] no I'm
straight in yeah she trusts the way she
raised me yeah we never worried about
him ever so my mom walks in she's like
what is that and she comes to she peels
the blanket back and she picks it up and
she's like
and I was like
and she's like
huh and she just starts laughing and
puts it down and walks out
oh oh God like I was like my life's over
I'm getting kicked out she's gonna
disown me I was like no this is how it
could
if you just didn't touch it she wouldn't
have noticed
she was coming in to say hi to Cody
because oh my God she's like a Jurassic
Park philosopher
they sense movement and so she she walks
out and then she goes outside and she
just like smokes a cigarette and I walk
out and I was like Mom I'm so sorry and
she was like why she was like why I
don't care I was like
what you're joking she's like I don't
why would I care how old were you I was
15.
was it cannabis or tobacco
tobacco you mean nicotine
yeah
oh damn she's like I don't why would I
care
but it's like it's still as a parent you
I don't know I feel like you can't be
cool with it no my mom's dumb all right
he was like 60 she looked at me she said
should I just let him smoke weed and go
what the [ __ ] wrong with you
I'm an adult
what's wrong with you what did you do I
supposed to be as a kid then what had
you turn out I was like yeah I know he's
gonna be fine
but it's like no why would you want to
encourage him he's not he's a straight
edge now do you give her [ __ ] for
smoking weed and smoking and stuff no I
don't care like I did I don't care from
like a young age young egg from a young
age my mom has always been like it's
it's a like it's not a bad thing yeah
yeah she's like from like when I was
like 10 she's like if you people smoke
weed that's okay the second I was way
too known the way she explained yeah the
way she explained it to me is she's like
dude food tastes way better you love
dogs dogs are so cool
and you're just like happier that's it
and I was like so it's not a bad thing
she's like no it's just some people do
use it and some people think it's bad
and blah blah blah and I was like okay
that was it still like the position from
what yeah yeah she almost welcomed it
yeah for him she was getting tattoos
like you should it's a secret she almost
wanted him to like find out what it is
to know and be like cool with it so
she'd be like oh I smoke he smokes he
smokes in my house like no no because I
was like don't let him [ __ ] smoke me
yeah
this is this is taking away my spot no
it bugged me it's like no he doesn't
like smoking weed why would you
encourage him he's like not down why
would you go tell him like yeah it's
okay if you want to start smoking don't
go tell him that let him in you need to
hear from you or say it you need to make
that choice when you're an adult yeah
yeah just don't tell him hey by the way
your girlfriend wants to move in and
live with you that's fine like that's
basically it's like yo don't give up
yeah he wants to smoke let him smoke but
don't encourage him until he's 18 you're
not yeah it just bugged me it bugged me
not because she was like that toward me
but more of like I'm not gonna do that
too much children what would you say
what percentage of kids that you went to
school did you go to a school with a lot
of kids or no oh there's like 4 000 kids
in my school were all of them vaping or
doing extra [ __ ] oh look even text me
caught like hey I walked in these kids
were watching a video and vaping me wow
how many were at horrible odds with
their parents
would you say was it I I honestly I
don't really know but like a lot of
parents were like that's bad but they
were like secretly doing it at school
but it's also so easy now you get a cart
that's it you can smoke in class kids
smoke in class blow it into their
backpack that's it instantly that's it
I've seen the funniest stuff it was
sorry honestly though it's hilarious
because seeing that one kid at the back
of class just like
it's bad though these kids are smoking
cards they can get oh it might be a
streetcar no no no they're all fake all
of them are fake and all the kids all
the ones Mario Karts yeah and that was
the big bad one and all of the um
ones that the kids were selling all of
them were fake none of them were real
none of it was real everyone was gonna
all like
30 of the kids are gonna get cancer from
that 100 straight vitamin E nothing else
hot dry water vitamin E gross bad all of
it's fake that well it's also like we
can get what we can yeah yeah we're 14.
it doesn't matter it does don't breathe
in that stuff happy birthday sir thank
you wait have we been here those are
chocolate actually no just passed I
don't think so Steelo trapped the day
before that's right yeah this is my
birthday
um shout out to Rosie Rosie is hurt from
surgery still she's doing really good
Rosie set up this crazy ass sick ass
[ __ ] dope ass [ __ ] birthday [ __ ] I
know but also you're going to watch the
bill what are the odds it was literally
the same exact a lot of stuff went wrong
she like texted me and told me about it
and I'm like the it's the literally the
one time I'm doing something I couldn't
I know the one time [ __ ] so Rosie set up
this thing Rosie's the bougie rose that
was it was awesome
I wore vans though and pushed tree [ __ ]
because obviously
um Rosie set up a [ __ ]
birthday party on the roof of Burberry
in in Rodeo Drive and we got like a
bunch of [ __ ] to try on and got a bunch
of [ __ ] like they had like welcome happy
birthday Thomas I was like [ __ ] this is
crazy
it was awesome it was I won't say that
never mind it was really really cool we
were chilling it was awesome we got to
try [ __ ] on they had a dressing room for
us I felt like a straight adult it was
weird it was so cool right and then we
went right after that which first off a
sprinter van picked us up and we just
took dabs the whole time [ __ ] awesome
it was so tired the Spider-Man picking
stuff in the warehouse right outside
took us and then all the Steelers and
Steelers are [ __ ] up really sorry my
friend's going crazy over here Steelers
are losing in silence just punching the
air over there and then um we went to
this restaurant John Hash House is the
busiest guy ever it's a restaurant
called el paseo El Paseo I don't know
it's [ __ ] hard to get into I don't
know
I own there's only one that you there's
for vegan [ __ ] anyway we went there
because and then but John missed his
[ __ ] flight and couldn't make it
so he was stuck in Florida so he missed
it I would have went to a [ __ ] vegan
spot anyway anyway it was super bougie
it was super cool like wow they have
like a [ __ ] well happy birthday I'm
like what
they're like it was cool like holy [ __ ]
there was like tables decorated I'm like
damn this is tight and we got [ __ ] face
came back here got shit-faced and that
was a long night it was cool but
Jade
told this guy Trent the wrong day
so as we were pulling up to Rodeo he's
getting on his flight in Hawaii he's
like what do you wait what hold on it's
today and his whole family his family
left town and they said you should come
with it he goes no I have a birthday
party I can't miss where'd they go to
[ __ ] Paris damn so he could be in
France instead of missing our party not
even done and he goes and I was like
banging this really hot chick and she
was in town a couple more days I had to
leave and that's what he told me he's
like
we're all having fun and then yep
exactly and no one's at the house and
sister sales because they all went to
Paris without him he got home alone [ __ ]
at two in the morning you got a cart
that's bent
they didn't even charge him tax or
answer his ID he just walked into a door
and bought drugs essentially
okay damn that ties right back into
where we started this conversation with
the fit cards yes yes they're all fake
so that's what we did for our birthday
and to wrap it back up what are we
talking about burger oh Louie
that's one of the shirts I bought nice I
was like you know what
I'm gonna wear this they're so sick
and yeah that's it that was the birthday
was [ __ ] cool Tom's got me these
shoes oh yeah I got in these [ __ ]
sick ass shoes
they're so sorry we gotta pop them up on
the screen yeah they're pretty cool very
[ __ ] and while you were doing that I was
partaking and the [ __ ] Super
Bowl champs getting goddamn dethroned in
their own house yeah so you know what I
mean that was the basis the team from La
that one the Bills beat the [ __ ] out of
them Marty got to go to the [ __ ] game
they'll drop the Super Bowl Banner they
announced that the Super Bowl Banner
that's it everybody's cheering and then
the the announcer
Sofi Stadium's crazy it's got that sick
ass wrap around screen so everybody can
see the screen dudes on dude on there
says he's like talking about how great
the Rams are and he's like yeah well as
long as Josh Allen doesn't come down and
score on the first drive because then
his confidence goes up and he's
basically Unstoppable and then they
[ __ ] cut and that's what basically
came out and happened I'm pretty sure he
scored on the first [ __ ] drive and
he's going to do that [ __ ] to the
Steelers when he sees them too yeah [ __ ]
the Steelers Justin what happened
that makes us cool like I said we're the
only ones that do that high level losing
yeah high level losing what the [ __ ]
where are you at they're consistent four
years in a row
[ __ ] ass you got sports teams with
multiple championships okay you're in
nowhere near a four consecutive losses
here
all right that was uh Dorian
a bullet mask
I will
um hold on real quick we just released
this for my birthday too for the
dopashop.com hemp blunt two grams of
weed one gram of wax in this
[ __ ] keep it dusted
you can eat them that's cool
you can eat them dab dude what I'm gonna
catch it right now Rocco's over here
smokeless and [ __ ] young
yeah big shout out to Nate [ __ ]
Diaz too that was an eventful [ __ ] we
could do a whole separate whole separate
podcast on that yeah man Rogan posted a
picture as I was walking in here
[ __ ] I don't know if it's real
tapped at 209
Stockton Nadia ZIP code or whatever [ __ ]
like what Mercy is that the same one oh
[ __ ] that's why I always scream 209 when
stuff says every time I see it unfolds
no every time I see it on a price or
anything I have to say it out loud it's
a mission that I have to do okay so
every time even if it's low I have to
say it verbally oh [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry
um so Rocco
what's your next step huh we asked every
guest what's your next step here what
are you gonna do fortnite
yeah get your home I honestly I want you
so much I want to work towards this
brand they make oh it says you're
modeling though yeah 100 okay this brand
that Brand's on Melrose huh so sick he
went in and they were magic shows they
were cool as [ __ ] to him so dude the
guy's working there so cool they were
like they were just homies hanging out
and I was like you guys have a cool job
and they're like dude we just watched
all the funny people walk by uh and I
was like you guys you guys are doing it
right it's like skiing stuff but it's
like really nice quality and like this
little tall [ __ ] and skinny and it looks
white but it could be [ __ ] not yeah
this is potential here yeah potential
good way to pitch him dude I wanna what
race you wanna look like we got it he's
whatever you want him to be mold them
for real though why couldn't it why
couldn't every time I go buy Gucci and I
see these [ __ ] kids with long hair
and go that's you yeah it could be the
next video 15 years you look just like
this [ __ ] kid on the ad he said he's
25 and you're 18. bro
I pay a lesson be like that's your first
campaign for real though for real so
that's what that's the next step
it's very fun yeah and I really like
being able to like look at all these new
clothes like I do really like clothes
it's real like it's just it's cool yeah
it's like stuff that I like to have
since you've been a kid having butt
because dude I'm into fashion heavy but
also it's the first I'm a [ __ ] fat
guy not skinny and tall so when I see
cool [ __ ] my yell around you should
probably you should get this here get it
get it because I know it looks tight
like yeah rocket because it's tight yeah
looks so nice it looks I can't wear it
you wear it tight so modeling for sure
moving down here
under your own spot you should get a one
bedroom with a closet and let this maid
I know from Pittsburgh live in your
closet and you'll take pictures and hear
your house
upright sleep upright [ __ ]
had a slit conserved space
to conserve space oh he's gonna sleep on
one of those decompressor beds no he's
gonna sleep in the closet just lean back
he's a vampire open Sylvania
OH
we might be all right Rocco you gotta
[ __ ] start posting your damn
Instagram what's your Instagram it is
[Music]
Boom popped up on the screen start using
this [ __ ] oh I will yeah uh you should
turn your YouTube into something too
what's that YouTube do you even have
access to it anymore yeah what's the
YouTube channel same [ __ ] same thing no
underscore watch it type in He Knows My
Name
um
little video of him with Optimus Prime
it's pretty [ __ ] cool this was a soft
episode my mom text Rosie yesterday
she thought we're just gonna sit here
and [ __ ] on her or something like yeah
she was like please don't I was like
what am I doing I was like no he's gonna
yeah I'm gonna and she was like
everything she's gone through on this
show like
is that even that like there's no
ammunition from him what's he gonna say
remember when you took care of me yeah
remember you were a better mom what the
[ __ ] was he gonna say it's all good yeah
she's great she's great yeah
um Marty you got anything else
thank you sir this was fun I've been
looking forward to this one yeah
this was really cool Rocco helps us with
the comments it's gonna be weird to do
comments on an episode I don't know [ __ ]
yeah and you're in that age bracket that
a lot of the fans are into so it's just
like it's cool oh to clarify I do the
live chat we're actually in the live
chat if it's us it's us Morocco helps
out with comments on some of the pages
not all the pages
podcast dopasiola that's it I do all of
them I do all the rest of them but I
still do some comments yeah you go in
there and hop in and do [ __ ] but to take
over a big chunk because yeah because
he's doing more hours yeah it's a job it
takes like two days yeah to do finish a
video yeah sometimes it takes way longer
but I still do comments I don't think
like oh I'm not even talking to Thomas
anymore like no it's [ __ ] in a way
you are he's an extension of me well
this little Tech will send me a [ __ ]
text how do you want to respond like
say this it's still time but it's
awesome though dude because it saves you
so much so much because you don't sound
crazy we are chunks of hours of days and
then also be the shower doing comments
and [ __ ] yeah when you're not on there
like oh what's up I'll hop in and just
hit chunks of them yeah but I don't do
the first thousand anymore I probably do
like 10 of them and then after the
Thousand he stops and then I'll go in
and start looking at [ __ ] in the
comments back and top comments and new
ones just whenever I have like 20
minutes I'll sit there and just do
chunks
is so much easier for him to do the live
chat though like I can't imagine him
doing a live chat and then having to do
so much 400 comments after the live chat
oh man would be seven hours a day ugh
yeah it's a full day too much time I'm
glad I can like take up a lot of it for
real yeah and I have the adventure
Channel we have the [ __ ] Clips
Channel we have all the yeah so much
other [ __ ] going on but um shout out
Instagram by the way well we've got
subscriptions going on the Jurassic
Graphics page now if you want to I
subscribe today you can subscribe and
there's a group chat I'll answer your
[ __ ] you got questions I'm gonna that's
a good way
I just said that that's a cool cool way
to uh
uh for me to communicate with everybody
where I'll actually be able to do it and
keep up with it because it's just it's
like a subscription for twitch ish but
for Instagram so Marty like you get the
back end
for live so just be you guys
wait you like pay for it yeah I signed
up this morning it's on Instagram it is
offered it today that's so cool so I'm
gonna go live but it'll just be for the
subscribers and there's a little chat so
I was going back and forth with some kid
tell me about his music and [ __ ] I saw
Andrew right yeah I saw it this morning
I just described yeah Andrew yeah let's
go there you go I love that that's
something I know I can keep up with one
clean thing I'm gonna do a couple lives
out there just aimed right at the
subscriber so I'm gonna check that out
perfect
all right Rocco thank you for being here
sober guest appreciate it was very fun
let's go this was great I love those see
cameras fun yeah oh he was it was it was
like it was weird it was like it felt
like getting on a roller coaster like
when you're in the line you're like oh
God yeah what's what's gonna happen yeah
it was fine it actually was like weird
oh there's nothing weird to ask the only
thing weird
oh my God stop saying [ __ ] like that
people are stupid as [ __ ] believe it you
have to you know how about this cut that
out most Sun Smarties don't do it
because there'll be times I'm like
broccoli you want to see his DM this
guy's [ __ ] stupid but yeah I know you
you do this and this and this and you
really sell this like
it's gonna be a bread and apartment
[ __ ]
God and then this fool does this [ __ ]
yeah and then people hits his brother he
probably
get it out there
stop no this Fool's an [ __ ] once you
understand the humor but they don't see
people exactly one day they will no it's
called they don't get the sarcasm
they won't ever get it because they're
adults at this it's not sarcastic
oh look at that face Steelers are losing
when they're beating Cincinnati he looks
so sad oh his face just changed at the
beginning
person
oh we're missing games like that I'm
[ __ ] up okay Rocco posting your
[ __ ] Instagram I will you're out of
school you didn't go to college so good
I might now you have more yeah well I I
finally realized I can get paid to do it
I was like wait what
that's a thing I don't know about that
uh that's Mark's getting paid to go to
school okay that's called financial aid
your parents do not make a little money
mom doesn't work mom cannot claim that
and live in the house she lives in we'll
see and drive the car that she drives
that's a great Point [ __ ] take
advantage of you said this to me that's
because Mom grew up poor
all right we'll see
okay probably not I'm probably not that
sounds even if you don't have you just
you just sounds so bad platformed his
whole College I might but I'm probably
not going to but even if you want to do
it I'm saying if you didn't go to school
now you have time let's do some [ __ ]
start a [ __ ] business you've never
had no one's ever had it easier yeah
without being a trust fund kid 100 you
know what I'm saying very cool let's do
it very very cool what to do we can do
it whatever you think you need to do or
want we'll get it
G sharp so start thinking and doing it
oh I will all right
on Instagram yeah I yeah thank you Marty
thank you sir thank you guys uh shout
out to the Steelers for crushing it
today they won Trent obviously didn't
have any towels or paper towels because
there's big hand wet hand prints on the
sides of shorts oh there it is he's
wearing yellow shorts with this big wet
hand prints up his [ __ ] legs
also guys on Instagram you guys booked
Steelo Brim by the way oh that's right
you guys been booking guests for us left
and right so malcol's taken over with
the guest book and it's starting to
happen but right now if this phase Reign
is that his name yeah no I used to watch
him like that'd be cool
because Marty posted steel brim we would
love to have him on tag him and then and
then moments later he's like yo what's
up oh if you watched last week's episode
he said he's like I got in my DM went
what the [ __ ] the thousands of comments
so many That's What DJ ghost said too DJ
go say things I want my DM well what the
[ __ ] dude even I'm in there yeah there
it is it like so if you guys want
Facebook Marty posted today tag his ass
let's run it
that'd be really really cool no no he'll
explain so much that's like the era that
I grew up with that I grew up with it
like FaZe was like I was watching that
when they were still in the little face
out the brick face house it was crazy
that's why there's a different
generation super cool you're gonna
consult us on that one yeah I do I wanna
I'm gonna be here I run it by Rocco when
they when they send us like popular
YouTubers what yeah get them so that's
why I do [ __ ] when it was a younger
Chronicle Rocco do you like these people
who is this yep around it he's not gonna
watch anything lame yeah so it's like a
little pass yeah as he passed Rocco's
yep all right we're good
um yo it's crazy smoking an actual blunt
it's burning so slow yeah we know it's
like chilling I haven't smoked for
[ __ ] like 20 minutes all right thank
you for being here man we appreciate you
for having me it happened very soon it
did it did it did he's not even high I
asked you won't be a podcast tomorrow
and I told him maybe we'll be podcast
tomorrow he goes tomorrow I was like
wait tomorrow really
we switched it around
they lost some intensity back here it's
not looking real good he's morning he's
morning
oh so it's still a ball game
all right there's still a chance so
you're telling me there's a chance all
right let's get out of here I'm sorry
for everyone driving out there please
please be safe for everyone hanging out
thank you for hanging out watching uh
just in case do us a favor like the
[ __ ] video do it no matter where
you're at it does help it does help
charcoal helps with it you'll see it
like I notice it oh man the problem is
going crazy it's not age restricted yeah
there's like so we did a thousand in a
night
quick that's rare quick last night's
story time was not age restricted crazy
three or four hundred comments by the
time it was over all right insane crazy
with so many chat was going so fast you
can couldn't see the names that's why
what happens when we're not ages people
like whoa I haven't seen you [ __ ] in a
while yeah exactly dude so many people
are like dude I haven't seen anything in
four months because YouTube unsubscribed
me yeah it happens a lot I I did like
the little subscription box nothing so
dude YouTube is hating yeah it sucks but
I'm trying to hold you back we're trying
we're trying to do our thing but
Marty thank you very much thank you sir
Rocco thank you very much thank you sir
all right now everybody's really gonna
ask for Shireen to be on here and my dad
oh let's do all three of us that would
be cool
it would be you mean my mom
that would be that's not really cool
because it will tame Shireen a little
bit and she won't be such a dick
um
stories
yeah we could do that yeah let's figure
this out we'll figure this out we'll
figure this out all right guys thank you
so much for watching appreciate it I am
dopa Zola Thomas whatever you want to
call me this has been the dope usual
podcast we're gonna talk about live
drugs problems accomplishments in
fortnite
and fortnite and Minecraft
[Music]
he caused all of it I'm telling you stop
we're out of here guys thank you so much
have a dope ass day gotta shut the [ __ ]
up on things that you don't get us in
trouble everything does it matter
different does it matter
get killed say that [ __ ] after we're off
the [ __ ] show
I'm gonna go back in time and prove it
[Music]
thank you
perfect